in Santa Cruz Chile the February 27th
earthquake knocked this three-story
apartment building down to two storeys
everything on the first floor was
crushed 23 people died here the malli
region which includes santa cruz a city
of about 30,000 and the neighboring city
of curico was one of the most heavily
damaged in chile most of the country's
deaths occurred in this region it's
Chile's leading winemaking region and
while nearly a million people live here
most are in rural areas there are no
skyscrapers here but the damage is very
clear everywhere the eye or the camera
turns even late in the week there was no
electricity and no water in many of the
surviving homes and food is scarce
while many roads are reopen travelling
is still difficult with dangerous cracks
and breaks blocking the way aftershocks
are nearly a daily occurrence in the
region some as high as 6 point 6 on the
Richter scale this is several days after
the initial 8.8 earthquake that sent
tsunami waves over Chile's coastline the
country's president says it could take
up to four years to rebuild from the
devastation and that reconstruction
costs could approach 30 billion dollars
u.s. President Michelle Bachelet has
declared a three day national mourning
period beginning Sunday for victims of
the quake
you